another potential strategy which is uh i
think especially helpful for breaking up
uh
long periods of sedentary activity uh is
using something called exercise snacks
and this is something that's gotten
it's picking up some momentum in the the
peer-reviewed literature but it's
basically these really short isolated
bouts of vigorous exercise that are
performed for very short periods of time
but done periodically throughout the day
so
for example you might do
three 20 second intervals of vigorous
stair climbing like
literally what this looks like is you're
at your desk job in the office
step away from the desk uh instead of
walking to the water cooler you go to
the stairwell 20 seconds hard catch your
breath 20 seconds hard catch your breath
20 seconds hard catch your breath boom
you're done for the hour and so like
you'll find different approaches to this
concept of exercise snacks but generally
speaking
it's you know you might do something
really short every hour on the hour
but of course you can adapt that do it
every other hour there are also some
that are a little bit longer that are
kind of closer to like five minutes but
you would do them maybe every three to
four hours but the general idea is
scheduling in
planned regular breaks you know the
previous list of activities was
more oriented toward
i'm gonna do something that has a
a different purpose but i'm getting
physical activity as i'm doing it right
i'm mowing the lawn because my grass is
long but it's nice to know that i'm
breaking up my sedentary time but for
this it is exercise for the purpose of
exercise and it's done on a more regular
schedule and done several times
throughout the day and so what they try
to do with this approach is do uh
interventions with a lot of ecological
validity and a lot of practical
utilities so they try to do things like
stair walking brisk walking air squats
uh sit to stand like basically chair
squats uh body weight calisthenics the
idea is that you could in a
a wide range of occupations
take a second go do this for three four
minutes get back to your chair and not
be disruptive and not have to like drive
to the gym change clothes take a shower
etc
so this is an area of research that is
just getting rolling but
these are some nice strategies if you're
someone who was uh really
interested by greg's previous segments
about walking but you don't necessarily
do that well psychologically with uh
highly uh quantitative approaches to
exercise if you prefer to or if you just
don't have time to get in that many
steps like it is time consuming exactly
yeah but you know i the the
time-consuming component is big but i've
also seen instances in the physique
athlete world where people
will tend to take things to extremes you
know psychologically it is an extreme
endeavor and sometimes people respond
really unfavorably when you say hey try
to walk 15 000 steps per day and it's
like they are so fixated on that number
all day it's it's really uh detrimental
to quality of life for some people so
there's a lot of ways to break up your
sedentary activity and there's ample
evidence to suggest that it can be a
really positive thing to do so so i've
actually got
an anecdote related to exercise snacks
cool so back in the day uh
i think we've talked about this on the
podcast before i read a book
many of you have probably heard of
called the four hour body by tim ferriss
and
do not count this as a recommendation to
read that book there's
some good practical advice
mixed with some uh not so good advice
not the best signal-to-noise ratio
you'll come across uh but
one of the things he recommended uh
for
i think completely incorrect reasons did
has actually turned out to be relatively
helpful for me um
so he had this whole section about just
like hey how how can you use the magic
of nutrient repartitioning to
ensure that you can eat a bunch of food
and and not gain any fat he was like
well so look uh
yeah you have these these glucose
transporters and muscles and if you just
do 40 bodyweight squats before a meal
that's going to cause a ton of
non-insulin mediated glut4 translocation
all of those carbs you take in they're
just gonna they're just gonna go
straight to your muscles there's no way
they could possibly meet any other
metabolic fate so boom you've hacked
your metabolism uh and all it takes is
40 body weight squats wow and uh so yeah
that's
that's not true
uh but
um
you know when i first encountered that
information i was uh much dumber and
more naive and i was like okay okay i'll
i'll give this a shot um
and
so i didn't i didn't uh
uh notice
physical effects that
comported with what i was told to expect
in the book but uh what i did find is
just that doing some bodyweight squats
from time to time did just help me feel
mentally sharper and and kind of feel
better um so i've actually developed a
bit of a habit where
like not every time but most of the time
when i use the bathroom i just do like
20 bodyweight squats before i leave
while you're
using
uh
yeah i mean it's so it's it's it's good
for practicing your aim there's a
you know it makes a day-to-day activity
kind of like a mini game
that you might play in like a mario
party or something but no uh
no and afterwards um
and uh yeah like i i find that um
you know it just helps get the blood
flowing i find that i have more
like i feel more energetic and just have
more mental clarity after that um
and yeah it's very simple so that's uh
something at least anecdotally that has
that has been helpful for me